(upbeat music)
- [Brent] What number are you on?
(car revving)
(upbeat music)
- Yo. What's up?
- What's going on?
- Tell us, tell us about your place.
- Well we do whole hog barbecue here.
That's what makes us special.
And we cook it with just wood.
There's no gas in here, only smokers.
It takes about 12 to 15
hours to cook a pig that way.
We cook the pig until it's an
internal temperature of 193.
All that fatty goodness
just starts to melt at that
temperature and then it just
kind of melts and just pours
through the meat and the meat
instantly changes texture.
This is a sauce that
we just started making.
I'm calling it XX Red.
It's just a spicy red sauce.
Tomato based, there is some vinegar.
We cook it underneath
the pig and it's just
getting dripped on and getting a layer
of smoke from that bottom of the pit.
- Wow. That's not bad.
(upbeat music)
(car revving)
Where are we?
- We're at Lexington Barbecue,
Lexington, North Carolina.
- What are you guys known for?
- We're known for smoking pork shoulder.
All we do is salt on it.
We don't baste it, we don't inject it,
we don't put any sauce
on it until you order it.
- What am I about to eat, like
explain to me what's on my plate.
- Original barbecue plate
always comes with a 'slaw,
chopped barbecue, french
fries, hush puppies also.
- How long you guys been around?
- Grandpa started at 1962.
Used to be a gas station
and a radio station.
I think it had two tables in it.
But ever since then we're
selling on an average week
we'll feed 7,000 people a week right now.
Yeah I mean nothing's changed, really.
We still fire the pits the same way,
the same amount of time.
- Hell yeah.
- Love that.
(car engine starting)
(upbeat music)
- My name's Sam Jones.
Welcome to Skylight Inn Barbecue.
So our family started
Skylight the summer of 1947.
This year actually makes
70 years that we've
been doing the same
thing every single day.
My grandfather opened at age 19.
He had a third grade education.
One of the smartest men
you ever meet in your life.
The staple is whole hog
pork chopped by hand
that was cooked for 18
hours, lightly seasoned,
topped with a piece of
cornbread that the recipe
has been the same for almost
100 years with a coleslaw
recipe sitting on top of that
that's 70 plus years old.
That's not just a paper
boat with pork in it.
That's a piece of North Carolina history.
- Actually, we didn't talk about this.
Oh. Damn, I'm so sorry about that.
- And this sauce that he
just poured on my pants.
(laughter)
It's a thin sauce that comes
out real easy on your jeans.
Barbecue shouldn't be defined by sauce.
It should be defined by how
it's prepared and what it is.
In Aden, North Carolina, whole hog
wood fire barbecue is what barbecue is.
- Thank you so much, Sam.
- Sam Jones university.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- Started on the corner in '72.
We didn't have much.
Sam my brother-in-law, and my wife,
and Dominique is my grandson.
I did a little bit of mechanic.
- That's why you guys
wear mechanic shirts?
- Yeah.
We do a hog in the back
and do mechanics up front.
We changed and went on to barbecue.
- What's special about your barbecue?
- Sauce.
- [Kwesi] The sauce?
- [Roosevelt] Yeah.
- [Kwesi] What's in the sauce?
- [Roosevelt] Vinegar, pepper, that's it.
Once you eat it one time,
you gonna come back.
We have people from all over the world.
- Did you say that you
eat this for breakfast?
- Yeah. I eat it all the time.
(upbeat music)
(car engine revving)
- My name's Chris Bare.
We're at Sweatman's Bar-B-Que
in Holly Hill, South Carolina.
Serving whole hog barbecue
cooked over a real wood fire.
The restaurant proper
has been here since 1977.
Originally started and
founded by Bub Sweatman.
He started cooking whole
hogs in his backyard,
selling it out the back of
his pickup truck in the '50s.
It became popular enough that he
decided to buy this old farmhouse.
Mustard sauce is just, I
mean, really that's all it is.
It's not a fancy barbecue sauce.
I's just gonna be mustard,
little bit of sugar,
little bit of vinegar,
little bit of pepper.
- So good. I honestly
can't stop eating it.
- It's kind of a regional low
country South Carolina thing,
but it's what Sweatman's has
done since its inception.
Just compliments the pork perfectly.
You get that little bit of
smoke, little bit of fat,
then you get that sweetness and that tang.
The mustard kind of cuts through how rich
that meat is and it's
the perfect combination.
- We appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you guys for coming, man.
I appreciate it.
- Can we get seconds?
- Yeah, go back man, go ahead.
- I think that's thirds, though.
- Yeah, no that is thirds for him.
- I just didn't want to leave, you know.
(upbeat music)
- [Brent] What is it that you guys
are doing here that makes you different?
- Beef barbecue, which is
pretty much a Texas thing.
Start off with certified Angus
beef, USDA prime, brisket.
Put our dry rub on it then
we smoke it over all wood
and offset indirect smokers
that we custom built ourselves
and it takes about 18 to 20 hours
to cook a brisket all the way through.
So we've got the lean end
of the brisket down here.
- Yum.
- And here's the fatty side over here.
This lays over the top as the lean muscle.
There's a little bit of burnt
ends from the fatty side.
- You built the smokers
yourself with your bare hands?
- Yeah.
- You can weld?
- Where'd you learn how to weld?
- Trying to figure out how
to make lighter cupids.
- Wow.
How long did that take?
- [John] A couple years.
- [Brent] What was so shitty
about other barbecue pits
that you were like I
have to make this one?
- Yeah. I made ones specifically
designed to cook brisket
and that's after, you know,
years of trial and error.
Cheers. Thanks guys.
- Thank you.
- Glad to have you.
(upbeat music)